c'est du piment dans les mots du miel
dans le paysage ça fait l'effet du café
dans les veines la poésie c'est cette
succession de mots capables de révéler
nos émotions et transmettre le frisson
lui dire l'union pour la défense de
l'identité réunionnaise organisait hier
une discussion littéraire consacré au
fond du coeur
cet art de la poésie en créole qui anime
l'écriture de sandra emma la jeune femme
signe un ouvrage intitulé volcan
d'émotion j'essaie d'expliquer mon choix
de quitter finalement le milieu
professionnel
l'année dernière j'ai décidé vous
décrire pourra compter quelque part à
travers ses fans car ce qui m'avait posé
problème en espérant et j'espère
toujours parce que je suis pas arrivé
que bas que j'aille mieux en fait
militants enthousiastes pas triste
retardé fin le fond coeur parce qu'il
véhicule
toute la singularité de l'identité
réunionnaise monde et ninive y appelle
le capitaine des mots aux coupes
beaucoup et peau écrit peau causés il
faut le mot et nous mêmes nous pays
des fois on était trop un pays parlent
pas ils causent pas un pays dans le
silence traitement mon pays le rendement
bavent aimant mip utilise la poésie
mutis le mot mais pour mettre mon pays
en l'air nous les en train de payer nous
gbagbo et moi mais mon peuple
le jeunot qui nous donne moko s'adresse
à nous autres promoteurs de l'âme de la
réunion jean marie barré et danyel waro
ont tenu à démontrer sa beauté
linguistique une soirée fonds coeur en
partage et en musique
[Musique]